what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
lapis
network um it's a girl that says i
apologize i didn't treat you right heart
to heart with my child's father i just
saw this i think it was just posted it
just looked interesting to me
so i decided to react to it live before
i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel and bring
that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my
daily videos hold on guys let me exit
out of this
okay oh god
when you know i apologize to you and you
said he was proud of me
hey hey hey what's going on family this
is your
renaissance bill courtney michelle uh
digging deeper today and
i am going to do something different
um i wanted to talk about
single motherhood and i had this whole
spiel about what i was going to say
and i decided not to
i decided to be transparent
and i decided to bring on
the man that is the father of my
child his name i'm
wondering how they convince how people
convince their relatives to have these
like private conversations
in on a public cloud jonathan
um he is an amazing man and we have
a story
an interesting story but something that
i cherish
and so i want to bring him on
um i think in the shows before i talked
about me
wrecking my home and
something that was interesting that
before
um he told me when i left he said hey
you
working at home i didn't understand it
then
i do understand it now and i just want
to tell this story because i think it's
important
to say because i know a lot of people
are in my situation
i'm like tearing up a little bit
this sounds like i don't know it's
really authentic when you see someone
like
really make a mistake and regret it and
learn from it
and um let's try to grow be better and
see how we can make it better so
uh yeah jonathan
are you here i am here thank you thank
you i'm here
hi all right so i don't
i know you you know that i do this
and um i don't know if you've watched
but you've been a topic of discussion a
couple times
um because sometimes people are like
well who
is he and she's a single mom and she a
baby mama
you know so i get that and
um for me
i don't consider myself
a baby mama um
it took me a minute to say i'm a single
mother
because i'm not i have the best support
you i have
i mean you've been there
the entire time so
i want to give you a voice
because sometimes i think that men like
you are silenced and you shouldn't be
so i want to ask you a couple questions
i want you to be honest
and let's just see how this rolls all
right i'm down
all right so um in previous shows i said
that i
wrecked my home because you know i left
and the reason why i left was
i was like we are in a whole toxic
relationship
um but back then i didn't take
accountability
to the fact that i was the toxic one
so i want to know how you felt
how did you how did you feel when i left
the home
well i would say you know first i would
say that you were not the toxic
the toxic one uh just you know it takes
two people to be in a relationship
you know and it takes two people to work
at it
uh to be in a healthy relationship you
know so we hear
the word unilateral relationship a lot
just
kind of meaning one person is working at
it more than the other
um you know but i would say that
most importantly i i think i was
heartbroken because
uh i look at myself as the protector
type
in a way and you know um you know just
being that
there was a new addition to the family
um you know i you know still do but
at that time your duties as a man really
sinks in as far as what you're supposed
to do
now that you have a a daughter um
you know so it wasn't you can hear the
pain in his voice
that's so sad just that you left it was
that the two of you left that um
you know really you know uh was
life-changing for me
and this is the thing they don't talk
about like
um i'm always very thankful that like my
parents stayed together
no matter what and the one thing you
don't realize
that if you leave you go from seeing
your dad every single day
to every other weekend and that's that's
a very different relationship
than if you grow up with someone like
there
and i could even see firsthand how it
became like
when we had a nanny and when we didn't
have a nanny like how much more
i interacted like with my parents
um i mean like they
they did the best they could we had 10
kids obviously like that's
a ton but i think that a lot of like
women don't realize
when they leave like what that does to
the kid you know so
for the most part yeah
um i would say
at that stage at the beginning when i
decided to leave
um there was a lot of resentment
i know that you had some for me and
rightfully so
again like you say that it wasn't that i
left you know our child left
and she wasn't in the home which we were
used to
24 7. um so there was a lot of
resentment and
it took us a while to get over that
resentment
and it might still be some there
um
but what i do want to know is how how
did we get from there to here
yeah um and you made a good point about
the resentment part
you know but that kind of fades away
over time
you know when uh two people just focus
on
um you know oh i don't know how old the
daughter is the new addition you know
the child the most important um
i think that going through what we went
through
as far as different legality situations
and things like that
because the love for you never left you
know that was always there always will
be there so
actually going through the legality
situations
was what hurt the most and eventually
i had to tell myself as a man hey you
know um
you know this is an awesome person
amazing
amazing mother of my child so that's
what matters the most to me
just kind of understand that you know
hey at that point in time we might have
just been in two different
you know parts of our life what we
wanted to do
um and then you just kind of
really just let that kind of fade away
and really start to understand that hey
i still care for this person
uh and what we created and i want to do
all i can to make sure that this person
um you know doesn't feel like they're
alone
in this situation because me personally
as a man i knew that i wasn't going
anywhere
so it was like hey either you know
stick around like you want to do and
make it work and uh
you know or or do the opposite so the
opposite wasn't really a choice so
just kind of make it work yeah
well i would say this um man
there is a lot of regret that i have
um
[Music]
i would say that not
just you with that you know hazard great
in this situation you know
she's so sad but it's actually so
important
that they have conversations like this
in the open so keep people can see
the repercussions of their actions
because a lot of times people don't want
to admit
that they like did the wrong thing uh
regret looks
uh different depends on who it's coming
from you know
um the biggest thing is now somehow
years later you know we know hindsight
visions 2020 we both look back and
uh ultimately you know when two people
you know create something new you know
you got two people that don't have
children then you create something
together
um that means a lot
so you know i knew i was going to do
this jonathan
yeah you don't want me to do anything
i'm a whole emotional little lady
but regardless of that um
the one thing that i knew was
um i would have i never have
even when we were fighting back and
forth
our daughter was number one priority
yeah and i never did anything
for her not to be with you
and you know that i would never do that
like
she's a whole daddy's girl
you spoil her to death
[Laughter]
oh that's so cute to the point where i'd
be having a call you'd be like stop
obviously i'm actually telling stop
oh yeah yeah but you do
i want them to get back together i don't
know who he is but i want them to be and
um she is she's a big daddy's girl
and um
it's interesting because we're not in
the same household
but how we parenting well how we parent
her
it is kind of like we are like when you
have her
half the week i have her half the week
but even when you don't have her
you guys are face timing talking
throughout the entire that's so good to
hear
like that this conversation like makes
me really happy
because i i have like friends that
didn't have like a parent
in their life and i just see how it
really affects them
or affected them over time but like
seeing that they can
show that co-parenting is possible even
if you don't stay together
when she get in trouble i'm like i'm
calling your dad
like don't i be like jonathan
and i think it's like kind of vice versa
do you feel that way
yeah i do um and then you know you did
mention she's a daddy's girl
uh but um and now i would say honestly
that's what helped out a lot
you know um of course boy girl you want
to be there for your child but the fact
that my first
uh first born was a girl you know me
setting that example as a man and as her
dad
uh really means a lot to me um you know
so that's
uh it was really impactful as far as me
maturing
and adapting to a new life new lifestyle
and everything and just
you know uh just try all efforts to make
it work
most importantly yeah but yeah i would
definitely agree
season that is girl well let me ask you
a question
um and this is about
a conversation that we had
say a year a little bit over a year ago
where we were on the phone and like the
big baby i
am was crying um
[Music]
but it was a conversation where i
apologize
to you do you remember this conversation
i do
so i apologize to you because i didn't
treat you right
and then you told me that you were proud
of me oh god
i'm such a [ __ ] no it's all right
you're doing good doing good thank you
so would you say that you were
proud of me and i was like
what are you proud of me for
and i didn't understand it so
let's go back to that conversation when
you know i apologize
to you and you said you was proud of me
why were you proud of me well
i was proud of you then at that moment
the same way i'm proud of you today um
and the reason behind that is like i
said at that time when we were together
we might not have been on the same
accord as far as what we wanted in life
at that time
um you know you took that route that you
took
and you really did something with it you
know
um your homeowner you know your amazing
mom
you know um super supportive and
protective about child and you
everything that i would want
the mother of my child to be um
so even though like you said it was a
year ago and still a few years after
um we had broken up and just what you
did with that time frame was remarkable
to me
and i'll tell you to this day like i
told you then i i look up to you
uh and that helps a lot too um
you know with dealing with the past and
uh hurtful situations and things but you
take that
those lemons and you turn it into
lemonade which is
what i think we did uh and what i think
you did
so you are a shining example
of of zoe uh for zoe to look up to so
that's what i appreciate the most so
that's what i'm proud of because i
didn't enjoy it
wow that was such a cute video oh my
gosh i bet that goes viral i think i'm
early
um i think that was a really important
conversation to have just because that's
like a conversation that goes on
behind closed doors like people
regretting things and people wishing
they didn't do things and i think
there's a lot
especially with women there's a lot of
conversations that happen behind
closed doors where they do regret like
choices that they've made or things that
they've done including leaving like a
relationship like that
so let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree with that
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
i'll talk to you guys
next time